Uber is making a renewed
'super app' push.
The company that
has come to dominate
western ride-hailing markets
has partnered with Expedia
to allow users to book
travel within its app.
The move forms part of a
longer-term ambition at Uber,
which wants to keep
customers on its platform
by offering them a
wide array of services.
The company expanded into
food delivery in 2019,
quickly followed by
groceries and shopping,
and, well now travel.
Uber chief executive
Dara Khosrowshahi
says that the move
of Expedia is also
designed to drive uptake of
the group's premium membership
scheme.
The group already has more than
50mn paid subscribers to its
Uber One programme, but it hopes
that by offering them a range
of discounts it
can drive uptake.
The only problem is
that 'super apps'
have had limited traction
in western markets,
where users seem to be tied
to individual services.
And there are other
challenges on the horizon.
AI agents, which can book travel
and undertake a range of tasks
on behalf of users, all threaten
to cut out middlemen like Uber.
Uber is responding by trying to
drive up engagement and entice
users to stay on its platform.